yeah it almost feels like there's this
element of you get one of two options
right to solve the problem the first
option would be a global coordination
where everyone trusts each other we come
together we create a new standard you
write off the old debt and we move
forward under Bretton Woods to write or
whatever you want to call it but that
involves complete trust of everyone at
the table to kind of coordinate and
agree together the other option is trust
no one
Hey which essentially is what bitcoin is
and the trust no one option means
there's gonna be no one in control
there's gonna be no one in charge and
you actually don't need to trust anyone
else because you have the full
transparency to verify you know kind of
blocks etc and so you either get 100%
trust or you get a hundred percent you
know no trust and I think you're
probably the same camp is I have like I
just don't see the world where everyone
comes together and coordinates and
therefore that would suggest then you
end up in a world where trust no one
ends up being the dominant I'm kind of
approach yeah and if you play that play
that for so game theory predicts that
the sum of every one is better when
people korako operate right but what
ends up happening is everyone
coordinated cooperating creates an
incentive for somebody to cheat right
and so as and so if you look at that
through through Bretton Woods or
anything else it even paid changing the
gold reserve so everyone cooperated
worlds in a great place and and then US
can't pay Vietnam wars and everything
else off the gold standard and causing
people not to cooperate as as much for a
while that fiat currency backed all
other world currencies for 80% of world
currencies and it looked like it was
going but you started manipulating at
which point every other currency has to
manipulate to the one has too many
plates to have their jobs erode as every
other currency so and that problem gets
bigger and bigger and bigger so if you
look through game three weapons
happening as you have quickly you have
cooperation and then then no cooperation
and then cooperation again and no
cooperation through a lens of the world
it's a simple example would be driving
in the carpool lane right if everybody
if the carpool lane is only used for
people who carpool it works really well
for people who carpool if a lot of
people cheat then incentive accrues to
those people who cheat and then if
nobody catches those people cheat
everybody cheats then there's no carpool
advantage right so is hope looking
through this whole thing through that
through that lens and countries and
currencies and everything else was a
really important thing but I would
totally agree with you I cannot see it's
a it's a small possibility but it's it's
improbable the government's today this
far away from from cooperation could
come together and cooperate on a global
scale that needs to happen to be able to
prevent kind of a reset yeah so it's
pretty crazy world we're living in
what's the one thing that would change
your mind like is there something that
could happen that could change your mind
about needing to move into the
deflationary world I don't think so so
if technology is deflationary and that's
not it and when I say if it is clearly
deflation arey it's that's not a guess
it's a fact
and if technology is moving into every
industry then then there's no possible
way that we can run an inflationary
world anymore without jerry-rigging a
system and that's what we're seeing
right it's it's that's why I say that
it's way more important let's just talk
about this is talk about the changes
that are that have happened and rebuild
a society that works better for
everybody using what's what the facts
are clearly pointing out